हेलो गाइस, वेलकम बैक। तो आज की इस वीडियो
के अंदर हम बनाने वाले हैं एक बहुत एडवांस
एआई असिस्टेंट जिसके अंदर हमने ब्रेन डाल
दिया है और उसको लूप पे रन कर दिया है।
कन्वर्सेशनल एआई बना दिया है। बहुत सारे
फीचर्स एंड सेटिंग्स डाली है भाई और बहुत
फास्ट है, एक्यूरेट है और एकदम फ्री है।
ठीक है? हेलो जावे। हाउ आर यू? गॉट इट।
होल्ड ऑन। आई एम डूइंग वेल। सर, इट्स नाइस
टू चैट विथ यू? हाउ कैन आई असिस्ट यू
टुडे?
केस और समथिंग लाइक दैट।
जस्ट अ मोमेंट प्लीज।
सर आई बिलीव जेफरी आइंस्टाइनली
जेफरी
वाली
ही इज लंग ब्रो ही लंग एंड वास बिल गेट्स
ऑलरेडी प्लानिंग कोरोना वायरस और समथिंग
लाइक दैट
वन सेकंड प्लीज सर दे नो क्रेडिबल एविडेंस
टू सजेस्ट बिल गेट्स प्लान द कोरोना वायरस
पेंडेमिक
छोड़ो जाने दो कुछ बोलूंगा विवाद हो जाएगा
भाई तो कुछ ऐसा हमने बना लिया इसको लेफ्ट
साइड पे एक्टिविटी पैनल है और राइट साइड
पे लाइव सर्चेस हैं जिसके अंदर से यह डाटा
उठा के लाता है और फिर जवाब देता है। ठीक
है? और यहां पे एक सेटिंग्स पेज भी है
जिसके अंदर यह जो लेफ्ट एंड राइट पे जो
पैनल खुद ही ओपन हो जाते हैं इनको आप बंद
कर सकते हो। और एक थिंकिंग इफेक्ट है यह
सब आपको समझ में आएगा आज की इस वीडियो के
अंदर। तो फटाफट से वीडियो को स्टार्ट करते
हैं गाइस। मेरे भाई अगर आपने अभी तक चैनल
को सब्सक्राइब करके बेल आइकॉन को ऑल पे
सेट नहीं किया है तो आप बहुत कुछ मिस कर
रहे हो। तो यार सब्सक्राइब के बटन पे
क्लिक करके बेल आइकॉन को ऑल पे सेट कर लो।
यार, हमें हमारे चैनल के 1 लाख
सब्सक्राइबर जल्दी से जल्दी कंप्लीट कराने
हैं। वी हैव टू हिट 100 के सब्सक्राइबर एज़
सून एस पॉसिबल। तो मेक श्योर आप चैनल को
सब्सक्राइब करके बेल आइकॉन को ऑल पे सेट
कर लो गाइस। और भाइयों अगर आपने अभी तक
हमारा Telegram का ग्रुप चैट जॉइ नहीं
किया है, मैंने बना लिया है। आप जाके चेक
आउट जरूर से कर लेना। लिंक मैं आपको
डिस्क्रिप्शन में दे दूंगा। अगर आपका कोई
भी डाउट हो, कुछ भी इशू हो, सब बंदे यहां
पे एक्टिव रहते हैं भाई। ठीक है? और जो
लोग यहां पे ज्यादा एक्टिव रहेंगे औरों की
हेल्प करेंगे, मैं उनको मॉडरेटर बना
दूंगा। और मैं जल्दी इस ग्रुप में जावे भी
ऐड करने वाला हूं ताकि आप जावे से बात भी
कर पाओ और अपने काम भी करवा पाओ। कोई भी
डिटेल आपको चाहिए हो, कुछ भी चाहिए हो तो
जावे आपको हेल्प कर देगा। तो मेक श्योर आप
जाके जॉइ कर लो। Telegram चैनल का भी लिंक
मैंने आपको डिस्क्रिप्शन में दिया है और
ग्रुप चैट का भी। ठीक है? एंड आई नो गाइस
आप में से काफी सारे लोगों ने मुझे
Instagram पे फॉलो नहीं किया हुआ। तो मेक
श्योर आप मुझे Instagram पे फॉलो कर लो।
यूजरनेम है द श्रेष्ठ कौशिक और मोस्ट ऑफ द
अपडेट मैं यहीं पे देता हूं। ठीक है? और
जाके जरूर से फॉलो करना। लिंक
डिस्क्रिप्शन में भी है। और मेरे भाई इस
वेबसाइट का तो कहना ही क्या है? jaws for
f1.com यह सिर्फ मैंने आपके लिए बनाई है।
जाओ इस पे एक अकाउंट क्रिएट करो। अकाउंट
क्रिएट करने के बाद सिर्फ ₹299 पर मंथ का
सब्सक्रिप्शन है। और इस सब्सक्रिप्शन के
अंदर आप jवा का जो लेटेस्ट सोर्स कोड है,
किसी भी ट्यूटोरियल वीडियो का डाउनलोड कर
सकते हो। विद इन सेकंड आपको कोड लिखने की
जरूरत नहीं है। और सिर्फ 5 मिनट के अंदर
पूरा सोर्स कोड सेटअप करके यूज़ कर सकते
हो। ठीक है? तो मस्त वेबसाइट है। अगर आपको
कोई भी इशू आता है, कोई भी प्रॉब्लम आती
है, ठीक है? तो आप यहां पे मेरे को
कांटेक्ट भी कर सकते हो इस फॉर्म को भर
के। तो यह वेबसाइट मैंने आपके लिए बनाई
है। सिर्फ जाके जरूर से चेक आउट करना।
मतलब सिर्फ ₹299 के अंदर आप लेटेस्ट सोर्स
कोड डाउनलोड कर सकते हो आज की इस वीडियो
का। अगली वीडियो का भी, उससे अगली वीडियो
का भी एंड सो ऑन। ठीक है? तो जाके इस
वेबसाइट पे अकाउंट क्रिएट करो,
सब्सक्रिप्शन लो। और भाई जो लोग कोड करना
चाहते हैं खुद से वो कोड भी कर सकते हैं।
आज के इस वीडियो के अंदर मैं आपको पूरा
कोड भी करवाऊंगा। डोंट वरी। बट अगर आप
स्किप करना चाहते हो वो थोड़ा हार्ड वाला
पार्ट और डायरेक्टली सोर्स कोड एक्सेस
करना चाहते हो तो सिर्फ एक क्लिक के अंदर
आप वो कर सकते हो इस वेबसाइट पे जाके।
गाइस आज की इस वीडियो के अंदर हमने अपने
एआई असिस्टेंट को और एडवांस कर दिया है।
बहुत सारे फीचर्स डाले हैं। इसके अंदर
हमने ब्रेन डाला है। टेक्स्ट टू स्पीच
एनहांस किया है। और भी बहुत सारी चीजें की
हैं। और इसको एक प्रॉपर कन्वर्जेशनल एआई
बनाया है। फिलहाल हमने इसके अंदर टास्क
एग्जीक्यूशन यह वो फलाना ढिंकाना भी कुछ
भी नहीं किया। लेकिन फिर भी यह बहुत
एडवांस है। यह हमारी सारी बातें याद रखता
है। ठीक है? हमने चाहे 1 महीने पहले की
हो, चाहे 2 महीने पहले और फ्री है, सब कुछ
बेस्ट है, फास्ट है, एक्यूरेट है, स्टेबल
है। और आप इसको कहीं से भी एक्सेस कर सकते
हो। चाहे वो आपका फोन हो, टीवी हो या पीसी
हो, कहीं से भी आप कर सकते हो। ठीक है?
काफी लोग मुझसे पूछ रहे थे कि भाई आपने
इसको अपने फोन के अंदर कैसे रन किया? तो,
अभी तो हम इसको कहीं होस्ट नहीं करने वाले
जब तक यह पूरा कंप्लीट नहीं हो जाता। बट
मैं आपको एक तरीका बता देता हूं। बेस्ट
तरीका है। ठीक है? आप यूज़ करो NG Rock।
ठीक है? लेट मी टेल यू व्हाट इट इज़। तो
सबसे पहले वेबसाइट पे जाओ। ठीक है? यहां
पे अकाउंट मतलब लॉग इनवॉगिन कर लो। सो
लॉगिन करने के बाद आपको यहां पे आना है और
इसको इंस्टॉल कैसे करना है? आपको क्लिक
करना है यहां पे पे। ठीक है? और इस कमांड
को आपको सबसे पहले यह वाली जो कमांड है
इसको कॉपी करके आपको यहां जाना है पावर
शेल के अंदर। ठीक है? मेरा ऑलरेडी
इंस्टॉल्ड है। तो मैं नहीं करूंगा। बस
आपको यहां पे जाके इस पे क्लिक करके एंटर
मार देना है। और आपका यहां पे जो एनg रॉक
है, इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा आपके कंप्यूटर के
अंदर। और उसके बाद आपको एक टोकन मिलेगा।
ठीक है? जो कि मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं।
यहां पे आपको जाना है और इसके बाद शो
ऑथेंटिकेशन टोकन पे क्लिक करके इस कमांड
को कॉपी कर देना है। ठीक है? फिर दोबारा
से उसी पावर शेल में जाना है। ठीक है? और
मतलब यहां पे जाके एंटर मार देना है। तो
आपका यह भी सेटअप हो जाएगा। और जब यह सब
कुछ सेटअप हो जाए, सारा काम हो जाए। एंड
गाइस उसके बाद सब कुछ होने के बाद आपको
यहां पे टर्मिनल ओपन करना है। और यहां पे
कमांड लिखनी है एनg rock http
8000।
ठीक है? तो आपको यह कमांड लिखनी है और
उसके बाद 8000 हम यहां पे क्यों लिख रहे
हैं? मैं आपको समझाता हूं क्योंकि जो
हमारा जावे है वो 8000 पोर्ट पे रन कर रहा
है। आप देख सकते हो। ठीक है? यही वो जावे
है जो आज के इस वीडियो के अंदर हम बनाने
वाले हैं जो कि 8000 पोर्ट पे रन करता है।
तो बस आप यह कमांड डालो एंटर मारो। आपको
एक यहां पे लिंक मिलेगा फॉरवर्डिंग का। इस
पे क्लिक करो तो आप देख सकते हो विजिट
साइट जैसे ही आप करोगे आपका jaws यहां पे
एक टेंपरेरी डोमेन पे होस्टेड है। और यह
तब तक चलेगा जब तक आप यह टर्मिनल ओपन
रखोगे और आपका जो कोड है वह ओपन रखोगे।
ठीक है? जैसे ही इनमें से एक आप बंद कर
दोगे तो यह जो वेबसाइट है वर्क नहीं
करेगी। ठीक है? सो गाइज़ आज की इस वीडियो
के अंदर हमने jवा के अंदर ब्रेन भी डाला
है। वो डिसाइड करता है कि सबसे पहले जो
क्वेरी है वो जनरल है या रियल टाइम है।
ठीक है? पहले हमें यहां पे मोड सिलेलेक्ट
करने पड़ते थे लास्ट वीडियो के अंदर। अब
हमने एक ही रूट बना दिया है जावे का मेन
रूट। इसके अंदर हम सबसे पहले जो भी क्वेरी
देंगे वो पहले एi डिसाइड करता है कि ये
जनरल क्वेरी है या रियल टाइम क्वेरी। ठीक
है? और उसके बाद उसी चैटबोट से आंसर लेता
है जिसकी वो क्वेरी है और उस दौरान यह कुछ
ना कुछ बोलता भी है। कुछ एनिमेशन करता है
ताकि लगे कि हां भाई यह अवेलेबल है। ठीक
है? अगर मैं इससे कुछ पूछूंगा तो देखो
रिस्पांस बहुत जल्दी देगा स्टार्टिंग का
तो
वन मोमेंट
ठीक है तो
ओपन
तो जो स्टार्टिंग में स्टार्टर फ्रेसेस
बोलता है ठीक है यह भी इसके अंदर मैंने
डाले हैं ताकि ऐसा लगे कि जाvi बहुत फास्ट
है अदरवाइज अगर आप इनको बंद कर दोगे ना
मैं आपको दिखाता हूं
हेलो जावेज हु आर यू
अगर यह ऑन होता तो अब तक आंसर तो आई होप
आप समझे होंगे अब फटाफट से इसके
फंक्शनैलिटीज पे बात कर लेते हैं। सारी
चीज पे बात कर लेते हैं। तो गाइज़, यह
प्रोजेक्ट स्ट्रक्चर रहने वाला है आज की
इस वीडियो का। कुछ ऐसे करके फाइल्स एंड
फोल्डर्स हैं। लेट मी एक्सप्लेन। एक फ्रंट
एंड फोल्डर है जिसके अंदर एक इंडेक्स फाइल
होगी, एक ऑब फाइल होगी, एक स्क्रिप्ट फाइल
होगी और एक स्टाइल फाइल होगी जो कि हमने
लास्ट वीडियो के अंदर बना लिया था। फिर एक
डेटाबेस फोल्डर है जो कि बनता ही है। इसके
अंदर आपको एक लर्निंग डेटा बनाना है। इसके
अंदर आप अपना कंटेंट अपलोड करोगे और कोई
भी टेक्स्ट फाइल अपलोड करोगे एi उससे
ऑटोमेटिकली सीख जाएगा। वो उसके ब्रेन के
अंदर फीड हो जाएगा। ठीक है? और यहां पे एक
फोल्डर है ऐप करके। इसके अंदर दो फोल्डर्स
हैं। सर्विज और यूटिल्स। ठीक है? और गाइज़
आपको यहां पे इस फोल्डर के अंदर ऐप वाले
फोल्डर के अंदर तीन फाइल्स बनानी है। चार
फाइल्स बेसिकली। एक इनट फाइल, एक जनरेट
अंडरस्कोर थिंकिंग, अंडरस्कोर ऑडियो डॉ.py
वाली फाइल और एक मेन फाइल और एक मॉडल्स
फाइल। ठीक है? उसके बाद यहां पे दो
फोल्डर्स हैं। सर्विसेस और यूटिल्स। ठीक
है? और इनके अंदर ये फाइल्स हैं। लेट मी
एक्सप्लेन प्रॉपर्ली। आप देख सकते हो पूरा
प्रोजेक्ट स्ट्रक्चर यही रखना। कुछ भी इशू
नहीं आना चाहिए। कोई भी मतलब स्पेलिंग
मिस्टेक मत करना वरना आपको प्रॉब्लम्स
क्रिएट होंगी और आप फिर इधर-उधर घूमते
रहोगे। तो गाइस बेटर यही है कि आप अपने
सर्विसेस वाले फोल्डर के अंदर ये फाइल्स
बनाओ। कुछ छह हैं। ठीक है? और यूटिल्स
वाले के अंदर ये चार फाइल्स बनाओ और सेम
नाम रखना। अंडरस्कोर अंडरस्कोर सब सेम
रखना। ठीक है? वरना आपको इशूज़ आएंगे। और
बाकी ये जो फाइल्स हैं जो कि मतलब इतनी
जरूरी नहीं है। मैं आपको लिंक
डिस्क्रिप्शन में दे दूंगा। जैसे रीड मी
फाइल इसका लिंक आपको डिस्क्रिप्शन में मिल
जाएगा। कॉन्फिग फाइल इसका मिल जाएगा। ई
एनवी फाइल इसका भी मिल जाएगा।
रिक्वायरमेंट इसका भी मिल जाएगा और जो
बाकी है वह आपको लिखनी पड़ेगी। स्टार्टिंग
से मैं आपको लिखवा देता हूं एक-एक करके।
डोंट वरी। तो गाइज़ लास्ट दो-तीन वीडियो
से क्या हो रहा है। मैं आपको समझा नहीं
पाता प्रोजेक्ट। हम कर तो लेते हैं पूरा
कंप्लीट लेकिन मैं आपको कोड नहीं समझा
पाता एंड ऑल दोज़ थिंग्स। ठीक है? बट आज के
इस वीडियो के अंदर स्टार्टिंग में मैं
आपको समझा देता हूं थोड़ा बहुत ताकि आपको
आईडिया मिल जाए कि सारी चीजें काम कैसे कर
रही हैं। गाइस हम क्या बना रहे हैं, कैसे
बना रहे हैं, यह सब आपको पहले से ही पता
है। ठीक है? आ जाते हैं फीचर्स के अंदर
चैट मोड्स के अंदर। यहां पे हमारे पास तीन
चैट मोड्स हैं। एक है जनरल, एक है रियल
टाइम और एक है जाv। ठीक है? तो जो जनरल
वाला है वो जनरल क्वेरीज का आंसर देने के
लिए है। एक रियल टाइम है जो कि रियल टाइम
क्वेरीज का आंसर देने के लिए है और एक है
जाविस जो कि मतलब यूनिफाइड है एक तरीके
से। ठीक है? तो बेसिकली आपको समझ में आ
गया होगा। जनरल के अंदर जो कि जो जनरल
क्वेरीज होती है लाइक हाय हेलो बाय गुड
नाइट। जावे मेरे को बता दो पython क्या
है? और जावेज मेरे को गिटार बजाना सिखा दो
ऑल दोज़ थिंग्स। ठीक है? और रियल टाइम के
अंदर लेट्स से मैं बोलता हूं कि जावे मुझे
सर्च करके बताओ कि ट्रोन का प्राइस क्या
चल रहा है? क्रिप्टो का प्राइस क्या चल
रहा है या ऐसा कुछ? ठीक है? वह सबसे पहले
इंटरनेट पे जाएगा, वेब सर्च करके लाएगा
डाटा उससे सीख के रिस्पांस देगा। और जो
जावे मोड है वो यूनिफाइड है। वो पहले
सोचता है कि जो क्वेरी उसके पास आई है वो
कौन सी है? जनरल है या रियल टाइम है। ठीक
है? और वो सिर्फ एक सेकंड में सोच लेता
है। उसके बाद आंसर भी आ जाता है और वो
रिप्लाई कर देता है। ठीक है? तो ये हमारे
पास तीन चैट मोड्स हैं। अब गाइज़ बात करते
हैं टेक्स्ट टू स्पीच के बारे में। तो
हमने HTTS का यूज़ करके एक सर्वर साइड
टेक्स्ट टू स्पीच सिस्टम बना रखा है। पूरा
फ्री है और बेस्ट है। और सर्वर साइड क्यों
है? क्योंकि लेट्स से मैं अगर फोन में
जावा यूज़ कर रहा हूं तो फोन में आवाज
आएगी। पीसी में यूज़ कर रहा हूं पीसी में
आएगी। टीवी में ओपन करके टीवी में यूज़ कर
रहा हूं तो टीवी में आवाज आएगी। ठीक है?
और जो ऑडियो है वो सर्वर पे क्रिएट होती
है और वहीं पे प्ले होती है। और जो
सेंटेंस है उनको हम स्ट्रीम्स में मतलब
कलेक्ट करते हैं और उसी को हम बैकग्राउंड
के अंदर कन्वर्ट करते हैं और क्यू सिस्टम
बना के एक-एक करके उनको प्ले कर देते हैं
ताकि बहुत फास्ट वर्क करे। ठीक है? और अगर
आपको यह डिटेल में समझना है तो 15 तारीख
को लाइव आऊंगा 1:00 बजे या 2:00 बजे तब आप
आकर अच्छे से समझ लेना। एक-एक चीज एक-एक
लाइन का कोड बहुत अच्छे से समझाऊंगा। और
गाइस बात करें वॉइस इनपुट की तो यहां पे
हमने ब्राउज़र का नेटिव स्पीच रिकॉग्निशन
वेब स्पीच एपीआई यूज़ किया हुआ है फिलहाल
के लिए। इसको हम बाद में हटा देंगे। और
मल्टीलिंग समथिंग लाइक कुछ ऐसा वैसा
डालेंगे जो कि हिंदी और इंग्लिश एक साथ
सुने और मस्त वर्क करे। ठीक है? हर डिवाइस
में और यह वाला भी Chrome में, Safari में
हर जगह वर्क करता है। तो यह भी फिलहाल
मतलब बेस्ट है। बट बाद में जाके हम इसमें
मल्टीलिंगल डालेंगे। हिंदी और इंग्लिश
दोनों समझेगा या मल्टीज लाइक उर्दू और अगर
आपको कोई और भी लैंग्वेज बोलनी है तो वो
भी। और गाइज़ बात करें लर्निंग सिस्टम की
तो जो हमारा मतलब फोल्डर है, ठीक है?
डेटाबेस के अंदर लर्निंग डेटा वाला इसके
अंदर आप कोई भी टेक्स्ट फाइल डाल दो। तो
एi उनसे सीख लेता है। और जो चैट्स हैं,
ठीक है? वो भी सेव होती हैं। और चैट से भी
हमारा जो एi है वो सीखता है। ठीक है? और
हगिंग फेस का हमने सेंटेंस ट्रांसफार्मर
यूज़ किया हुआ है। और फेस वेक्टर इंडेक्स
यूज़ किया हुआ है। ठीक है? और यह मैं आपको
बहुत अच्छे से समझाऊंगा हमने कैसे
सिमेंटिक सर्च यूज़ किया हुआ है। एलएलएम
यूज़ किया हुआ है सारी चीजें। ठीक है? और
बहुत अच्छे से ये सारी चीजें ऑर्गेनाइज्ड
है, बाउंडेड है। तो मतलब एकदम मस्त वर्क
करती हैं साथ में। अब गाइज़ बात करते हैं
सेशन पर्सिस्टेंस के बारे में। तो जितनी
भी कन्वर्सेशन हम जावा के साथ करते हैं वो
हमारे कंप्यूटर के अंदर लोकली ही सेव होती
हैं। और जब हम रिस्टार्ट करते हैं अपने
प्रोग्राम को तो जो भी वो चैट्स हैं, ठीक
है? उनसे हमारा जावेद सीखता भी है। ठीक
है? और जो जनरल चैटबॉट है और जो रियल टाइम
चैटबॉट है दोनों एक ही सेशन मतलब शेयर
करते हैं ताकि जो कॉन्टेक्स्ट है वो
इधर-उधर ना हो जाए। ठीक है? अब गाइज़ बात
करते हैं मल्टी की एपीआई रोटेशन के बारे
में। तो यहां पे आप बहुत सारी ग्रो की
अलग-अलग अकाउंट से की बना के अपने ईएनवी
फाइल के अंदर डाल सकते हो और वह एक-एक
करके उनको यूज़ करेगा ताकि लिमिट ना आए।
ठीक है? वैसे मैं इस तरीके को मतलब नहीं
मानता हूं कि आप यूज़ करो। बट मैंने फिर भी
डाला हुआ है उन लोगों के लिए जो कि मतलब
अफोर्ड नहीं कर सकते। बट मैं आपको बोलूं
गाइस जाके सच में एक ही की यूज़ करो Grok
की पेड यूज़ करो। बेस्ट है क्योंकि यार
Grok फास्ट है। बहुत चीप है। ठीक है? और
मस्त है एकदम। ठीक है? और वैसे भी इसके
अंदर टोकन बहुत कम यूज़ होते हैं मेरे
सॉफ्टवेयर के अंदर। तो मतलब ज्यादा आपको
एपीआई कॉस्टिंग आएगी नहीं। मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं। मैंने बहुत यूज़ किया। लेट मी
शो यू। भाई मतलब लिटरली मैंने इसको कल यूज़
किया और आज यूज़ किया और दबा के यूज़ किया।
कम से कम 5 घंटे मैंने यूज़ किया है। ठीक
है? और आप देख सकते हो यहां पे कितना मेरे
को कॉस्ट आया है 5 घंटे का $.3 लेट मी
जस्ट गो एंड यू नो $3
इन एंड इट इज़ ₹27 ओनली मतलब 56 घंटे यूज़
करो तीन-4 घंटे यूज़ करो आराम से एआई को
मैंने मतलब टेस्टिंग भी की सब कुछ किया और
सिर्फ ₹27 इसने मेरे से काटे आप सोचो अब
मैं ₹27 को मल्टीप्लाई कर देता हूं 30 से
तो कुछ ₹900 बैठे महीने के और आप मस्त यूज़
करो अपने एआई को जितना बात करना है करो
भाई मस्त सारी चीजें चीजें। ठीक है? अब
गाइस बात करते हैं फ्रंट एंड के बारे में।
तो आप देख ही सकते हो हमने बहुत मस्त यूआई
बनाई है। एक ऑर्ब बनाया है। ठीक है? जो कि
एनिमेट करता है जब हमारा टेक्स्ट टू स्पीच
वर्क करता है। ठीक है? और हमने कुछ
थिंकिंग ऑडियो भी डाली है। मतलब लेट्स से
जो स्टार्टिंग के जो मैसेजेस होते हैं कि
वन मोमेंट प्लीज। ओ लेट मी थिंक अबाउट दैट
ऑल दोज़ थिंग्स। ठीक है? क्योंकि जो फर्स्ट
टोकन होता है वो थोड़ा टाइम लेके आता है।
इसलिए हमने यहां पे फ्रंट एंड के अंदर एक
थिंकिंग ऑडियो का सिस्टम इंटीग्रेट किया
हुआ है। रिस्पांसिव है और मतलब प्योर
html, सीएसएस, जावास्क्रिप्ट है। कुछ भी
टूल डाउनलोड करने की जरूरत नहीं है।
फ्रेमवर्क डाउनलोड करने की जरूरत नहीं है।
तो गाइज़ एक्चुअली यहां पे क्या होता है?
जब भी आप कुछ बोलते हो। ठीक है? तो वो
जैसे मान लो आपने यहां पे टाइप किया या
आपने बोला तो वो सबसे पहले फ्रंट एंड के
पास होता है। फ्रंट एंड जावास्क्रिप्ट का
यूज़ करके स्क्रिप्ट. जेS का यूज़ करके उसको
पोस्ट कर देता है। ठीक है? और बैक एंड को
भेज देता है। ठीक है? समझ में आया आपको?
एंड देन गाइज़ उसके बाद डिपेंड करता है कि
आपकी क्वेरी कैसी है। अगर वह रियल टाइम
हुई तो रियल टाइम के पास जाएगा। अगर वह
जनरल हुई तो जनरल के पास जाएगा। और अगर
आपने jवाs वाला मोड यूज़ किया है। ठीक है?
तो सबसे पहले वो डिसाइड होगा कि किस टाइप
की क्वेरी है। ठीक है? एंड देन उसके बाद
इन चैट बोट्स का यूज़ किया जाएगा। ठीक है?
मैं आपको और अच्छे से समझाता हूं। सबसे
पहले लेट्स से बैक एंड के पास रिक्वेस्ट आ
गई। ठीक है? अब गाइज़ मैं आपको बहुत बेसिक
तरीके से समझाऊंगा। बहुत शॉर्ट में
समझाऊंगा क्योंकि यार बहुत बड़ी हो जाएगी
वीडियो। तो जैसे ही बैक एंड के पास
रिक्वेस्ट आती है इन दो स्टेप के अंदर तो
वह एक jसon फाइल ही बनाता है जिसके अंदर
आपकी जो कन्वर्सेशन है वह सेव होगी आगे
की। ठीक है? जो भी आप करोगे एंड देन उसके
बाद लैंग चेन एंड ऑल दोज़ थिंग्स वेक्टर
डेटाबेस सब एक्टिव हो जाता है। उसके बाद
अगर आप जनरल चैटब यूज़ करते हो तो बिल्ड
प्र्ट एंड मैसेजेस वाला जो हमारा फंक्शन
है जो कि पूरा एक प्र्प्ट बनाता है जिसके
अंदर अगर वेक्टर डेटाबेस आपने यूज़ किया है
तो उसका डाटा आएगा एंड ऑल दोज़ थिंग्स। ठीक
है? सारी चीजें आएंगी। पर्सनल चीजें एक
पूरा प्र्ट बनके हमारे ग्रॉक के पास जाएगा
और वह रिप्लाई देगा। ठीक है? और अगर रियल
टाइम हुआ तो पहले वेब सर्चेस होंगी। ठीक
है? उसके बाद वो सर्चेस भी प्र्प्ट के
अंदर ऐड की जाएंगी एंड देन उसके बाद
रिप्लाई आएगा। समझ में आया आपको? स्टेप
पांच तक मैंने आपको समझा दिया। एंड देन
गाइज़ उसके बाद जब आंसर आ जाता है रियल
टाइम चैटबोर्ड का भी, जनरल चैटब का भी
दोनों का। उसके बाद वह फ्रंट एंड पे जाने
से पहले जो ऑडियो फाइल्स हैं वह क्रिएट
होती है और वह सर्वर पे भेजी जाती हैं।
उसके बाद फ्रंट एंड आंसर भी शो करता है और
एक साथ बोलता भी है। ठीक है? ऐसा कुछ होता
है। उसके बाद वो सेशन सेव हो जाता है। फिर
अगेन अगर आप कोई और सवाल पूछते हो। अगर आप
नई चैट ओपन करके पूछते हो तो एक नई आईडी
क्रिएट होगी सेशन। ठीक है? एंड देन ऑल दोज़
थिंग्स। और अगर आप उसी में पूछते हो तो
उसी के अंदर यह आगे चलता रहता है। ठीक है?
और नेक्स्ट स्टार्टअप पे जितनी भी चैट्स
हैं, लर्निंग डाटा है वो दोबारा से रिवाइज
हो के जो हमारा एआई है उन पे ट्रेन होता
है भाई। ठीक है? तो मस्त है एकदम इसको पढ़
लेना। वैसे तो बहुत सारी चीजें एक साथ हो
रही हैं। लेकिन यार पता ही नहीं चलता भाई।
मतलब जो एi सिस्टम अभी हमने बना लिया है
ना वो भी बहुत कूल है। ठीक है? लेकिन यार
ये फिर भी मैं बोलूंगा 5% भी नहीं है जो
हम बनाने वाले हैं इस ट्यूटोरियल सीरीज के
अंदर। ठीक है? तो ये कुछ एपीआई एंड
पॉइंट्स एंड ऑल दोज़ थिंग्स। ये सब आप रीड
कर लेना। आपको समझ में आ जाएगा। मैं चाहता
हूं आप ये पूरी रीड मी फाइल पढ़ो। इसका
लिंक मैं आपको डिस्क्रिप्शन में दे दूंगा
गाइस। ठीक है? और डेवलपर इसका ऑब्वियसली
मैं ही हूं। ठीक है? तो मेक श्योर आप चैनल
को सब्सक्राइब करके बेल आइकॉन को ऑल पे
सेट कर लो। 1 लाख सब्सक्राइबर हमने
कंप्लीट करने हैं एज सून एस पॉसिबल। ठीक
है? तो इन डिटेल मैं आपको बाद में
समझाऊंगा। तो चलो फटाफट से कोड लिखना
स्टार्ट करते हैं। सो गाइस यहां पे मैंने
पिप इंस्टॉल हफन आर कमांड रन कर दी है और
मेरे जितने भी पैकेजेस हैं वो यहां पे
इंस्टॉल हो रहे हैं। और जब तक ये यहां पे
इंस्टॉल हो रहे हैं। लेट मी शो यू। मैंने
यहां पे सारे के सारे एक्सप्लेनेशन और
कमेंट्स हटा दिए हैं इस वर्जन के अंदर
ताकि आपको कोई भी इशू ना हो कोड लिखने
में। और अगर आप चाहते हो पूरा
एक्सप्लेनेशन के साथ आपको कोड मिले। हर एक
लाइन का मतलब आपको समझ में आए। ठीक है? तो
आप वेबसाइट से सोर्स कोड डाउनलोड कर लेना।
jav f1.com से। जस्ट अकाउंट बनाओ। अकाउंट
बनाने के बाद प्रोफाइल पेज पे आप देखोगे
तो यहां पे आपको कह रहा है सब्सक्रिप्शन
ले लो। जस्ट इस पे क्लिक कर दो और आपका
रेजर पे खुल जाएगा और सिर्फ ₹299 के अंदर
आप सब्सक्रिप्शन लेके मस्त एकदम सोर्स कोड
डाउनलोड कर सकते हो। सो गाइज़ ऑलमोस्ट सारे
जो पैकेजेस हैं, वह इंस्टॉल यहां पे हो
चुके हैं। और जैसे ही यह इंस्टॉल होंगे,
मैं आपको एक-एक फाइल का धीरे-धीरे करके
पूरा कोड दिखा दूंगा। आप सेम टू सेम लिख
लेना और उसके बाद रन करोगे अपनी ईएनवी
फाइल बनाने के बाद तो एकदम मस्त वर्क
करेगा। ठीक है? और हर एक फाइल का जो कि
बड़ी फाइल्स है लाइक पूरा फ्रंट एंड
फोल्डर और लेट्स से जो कॉन्फिग फाइल है,
रीड मी फाइल है, रिक्वायरमेंट फाइल है।
ठीक है? और ईएनवी एग्जांपल फाइल है, इन
सबका लिंक मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी डिस्क्रिप्शन
में दिया हुआ है गिस्ट फाइल का। जाके
डायरेक्टली कॉपी पेस्ट मार देना है। ठीक
है? लेट मी शो यू हाउ। तो गाइज़ आपकी जो
ईएनवी फाइल होगी फाइल। ठीक है? फिलहाल
मैंने एग्जांपल फाइल बना रखी है। आपको जो
ईएनवी फाइल बनानी है कुछ ऐसे बनानी है।
ठीक है? और इसके अंदर आपकी ग्रो की की
होगी, टैवली की की होगी। और अगर आप
मल्टीपल कीज़ यूज़ करना चाहते हो, तो जस्ट
इसको कॉपी पेस्ट करने के बाद यहां पे
अंडरस्कोर 2 लिख दो। और अगर तीसरी यूज़
करना चाहते हो, यहां पे अंडरs 3 लिख दो
ऐसे-ऐसे करके। ठीक है? अलग-अलग काउंट से
कीज़ बना के आप यहां पे एकदम प्रॉपर्ली
इसको यूज़ कर सकते हो। ठीक है? तो, कुछ यह
स्ट्रक्चर रहने वाला है आपका ENV फाइल का।
और फिलहाल मैंने यहां पे ऑलरेडी बना रखी
है अपनी एक ENV फाइल। मेक श्योर आप ईएनवी
फाइल बना के यह डाटा यहां पे कॉपी पेस्ट
करके उसमें डाल दो। अदरवाइज़ वर्क नहीं
करेगा। यह एग्जांपल फाइल है। ठीक है? और
इतना तो मैं एक्सपेक्ट कर ही रहा हूं आपसे
कि आप इतना तो जानते होंगे। और गाइज़ यह जो
कोड है एनवी वाली फाइल का यह आपको मेरी
गिट रपोज़िटरी पे मिल जाएगा। आप यहां पे
जाओ। GH प्रोफाइल पे आप आओगे। तो अभी
मैंने जस्ट एक यहां पे गिफ्ट अपलोड की है।
इसका लिंक आपको डायरेक्ट मैं डिस्क्रिप्शन
में दे दूंगा। सीधा वहीं से कॉपी कर लेना।
और यह सारे कमेंट-वमेंट हटाने के बाद कुछ
ऐसा आपको देखने को मिलेगा। या तो
डायरेक्टली आप वीडियो में से देख के ही
बना लो। और अब बात करते हैं कॉन्फिग वाली
फाइल की। तो आओ इधर viुअल स्टूडियो कोड के
अंदर। आपको कहां से पेस्ट करना है? यहां
पे आप देख सकते हो मैंने एक फाइल बना रखी
है कॉन्फिग वर्जन 3। मैं लिंक भी
डिस्क्रिप्शन में दे दूंगा इस पूरे के
पूरे कोड को यहां पे आप कॉपी करो और
विजुअल स्टूडियो कोड में आके कॉन्फिग में
पेस्ट कर दो डायरेक्ट। बस इतना सा काम है
एज सिंपल एज दैट। सेम आपको करना है रीड मी
फाइल के साथ। ठीक है? तो यहां पे मैंने
आपको एक रीड मी फाइल भी दे रखी है। तो आप
देख सकते हो वर्जन 3 की रीड मी फाइल भी
है। इसको जस्ट यहां पे आप पूरे सोर्स कोड
को जो भी है इसका कोड है इसको कॉपी करो
नीचे तक और कॉपी करने के बाद आओ अपनी रीड
मी फाइल के अंदर और इधर इसको पेस्ट कर दो।
ठीक है? सेम आपको करना है
रिक्वायरमेंट्स.xt के साथ और यहां पे आपको
रिक्वायरमेंट.xt भी मिल जाएगी। इस पे आप
आओ और यहां पे आने के बाद इसको पूरा यहां
पे कॉपी कर लो और कॉपी करने के बाद इधर
आके पेस्ट कर दो। और यहां पे कुछ फालतू
चीजें भी कॉपी हो गई थी। तो कुछ ऐसा
दिखेगा यह। ठीक है? और तीनों चीजें हमने
यहां पे कर ली है। रन डॉटpy का यह कोड
होने वाला है। ठीक है? और एग्जांपल ENV भी
हमने सेट कर लिया है। अब हम बात करेंगे
फ्रंट एंड फोल्डर के बारे में। ठीक है?
मैं अभी इनको बाकियों को मिनिमाइज कर देता
हूं। और अब बात करते हैं फ्रंट एंड फोल्डर
के बारे में। तो अगर आप मेरी गिस प्रोफाइल
पे आओगे स्टाइल. CSSB और स्क्रिप्ट.b.jsb
और इंडेक्स.b सबका लिंक मैंने यहां पे
आपको दिया हुआ है। डायरेक्ट कॉपी पेस्ट
मारो। ठीक है? सबसे पहले आते हैं
इंडेक्स.html पे। पूरा का पूरा मैं ऊपर से
नीचे तक ये सोर्स कोड कॉपी कर लेता हूं।
करने के बाद आऊंगा मैं विजुअल स्टूडियो
कोड के अंदर। और जो आपने फ्रंट एंड वाला
फोल्डर बना रखा है उसके अंदर जो इंडेक्स
वाली फाइल है उसके अंदर आप यह कोड सीधा
आके पेस्ट कर दो। ठीक है? एज सिंपल एज
दैट। उसके बाद आपको आना है बैक और यहां पे
आपको ऊपर आना है। ऑफ डॉट जेs वाली फाइल पे
क्लिक करना है। वर्जन टू लिंक मैंने आपको
डिस्क्रिप्शन में दिया हुआ है। डायरेक्टली
वहां से आके आप एक्सेस कर सकते हो। अगर
आपको कोई भी इशू आ रहा है आप Telegram पे
मेरे को कांटेक्ट कर सकते हो यहां पे और
मस्त एकदम आपको यहां पे जितने भी आपके
इशूज़ हैं वो सॉल्व हो के मिल जाएंगे। ठीक
है? तो यहां पे कॉपी करने के बाद objs में
आओ और यहां पेस्ट कर दो। ठीक है? पेस्ट
करने के बाद नेक्स्ट फाइल जो है
स्क्रिप्ट. ठीक है? तो आते हैं इस पे।
लिंक डिस्क्रिप्शन में भी है। अदरवाइज आप
यहां से चेक कर सकते हो। स्क्रिप्ट जेएस
वर्जन टू। एंड देन अगर आप यह पूरा कॉपी कर
लोगे। उसके बाद आपको यहां पे आके इसको
पेस्ट कर देना है। ठीक है? एज सिंपल एज
दैट। एंड देन द लास्ट बट नॉट द लीस्ट
हमारी जो स्टाइल डॉट CSS है वह तो लिंक
डिस्क्रिप्शन में है इसका भी इसको हम यहां
पे कॉपी कर लेते हैं स्टार्टिंग से लेके
एंड तक और गाइस अगर आपने अभी तक चैनल को
सब्सक्राइब नहीं किया है तो कर लो भाई inा
पे भी फॉलो कर लो वेबसाइट भी विजिट कर लो
सब कुछ चेक कर लो ठीक है और यहां पे
स्टाइल डॉटcs जो है इस पे आके हम इसको
यहां पे पेस्ट कर देंगे कोड को ठीक है तो
अभी हमने जो हमारा मेन फोल्डर है वो सेटअप
कर लिया है ये सारी फाइल्स ठीक है एंड देन
उसके बाद हमने फ्रंट एंड वाला फोल्डर भी
सेटअप कर लिया है अब हम बात करेंगे ऐप
वाले फोल्डर के बारे बारे में। ठीक है? तो
चलो स्टार्ट करते हैं। गाइस, ऐप पे जाने
से पहले जो डेटाबेस वाला फोल्डर है, इसके
अंदर आप एक फोल्डर बना लो। लर्निंग
अंडरस्कोर डाटा और इसके अंदर यह फाइल्स
बना लो और उसके अंदर अपना डाटा डाल दो।
मैंने अपना डाटा डाला हुआ है। और यह थर्ड
पर्सपेक्टिव से डालना। ठीक है? मैं आपको
हर वीडियो में समझाता हूं। आपको अपना ही
डाटा डालना है। लाइक यू आर इंटरेक्टिंग
विद श्रेष्ठ कौशिक आर 21 इयर्स ओल्ड
ऑनलाइन एजुकेटर, बिज़नेसमैन एंड
प्रोग्रामर। तो ऐसे करके आपको अपना डालना
है। लाइक आप अगर आरव हो तो यू आर
इंटरेक्टिंग वि आरव एंड दिस दिस इज़ ब्ल
ब्ल ब्ल। ठीक है? तो इसके बाद आपको कुछ
नहीं करना। अगर आप यह वेक्टर स्टोर डिलीट
भी कर दोगे तो कोई दिक्कत वाली बात नहीं
है। खुद से बन जाएगा। ठीक है? तो गाइज़ अब
मैं आपको एक-एक करके इन सब फाइल का कोड
दिखाने वाला हूं ऐप वाले फोल्डर के अंदर।
तो स्टार्ट करते हैं सबसे पहले जो ऐप वाले
फोल्डर के अंदर दो फोल्डर्स हैं यूटिल जो
सर्विस इनको छोड़ के जो चार फाइल्स हैं
यहां पे मेन डॉटpy मॉडल्स py और जो जनरेट
अंडरs थिंकिंग अंडरस्कोर ऑडियो.py और ये
जो इनट वाली फाइल है। तो इनिट वाली फाइल
का कोड तो आप एकदम खाली छोड़ दो। कोई
दिक्कत वाली बात नहीं है। और यहां पे जो
जनरेट अंडरस्कोर थिंकिंग अंडरस्कोर ऑडियो
वाली फाइल है, इसका सोर्स कोड यह रहा। लिख
लो आप पूरा स्टार्टिंग से लेके एंड तक और
बिल्कुल सिंटेक्स सेम रखना कोई भी मतलब और
उसके बाद मेन डॉटpy का कोड मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं। यह थोड़ा बड़ा है तो आप देख लो।
और यह आपको कहां से मिलेगा मैं बता देता
हूं। ठीक है? यह अगर आप मेरी गेट रेपो पे
जाओगे। ठीक है? और यह आप अगर नीचे जाओगे
थोड़ा ओल्डर पे जाओगे तो आपको यहां पे यहीं
कहीं देखने को मिल जाएगा। यह रहा ठीक है?
jaws टाइटल py और आप इसको डायरेक्टली यहां
से कॉपी कर सकते हो। ठीक है? अब मैं आपको
आगे का कोड दिखा देता हूं।
सेम टू सेम आपको कोड लिखना है गाइस। मैं
आपको बता रहा हूं।
कोई भी इशू हो आप मेरे को कांटेक्ट कर
सकते हो गाइस। ठीक है? एंड देन उसके बाद
लास्ट फाइल मॉडल्स py तो उसका कोड ये रहा।
ठीक है? बहुत सिंपल कोड है। लिख लेना। कोई
दिक्कत वाली बात नहीं है। अब बात करते हैं
सर्विसेस वाले फोल्डर के अंदर जो छह
फाइल्स हैं उनका कोड क्या कहता है। ठीक
है? तो सबसे पहले इंट फाइल एकदम खाली छोड़
दो इंट फाइल। ठीक है? और ब्रेन सर्विस और
इसका जो हमारा प्र्प्ट है वो मैंने
अभी-अभी जस्ट गेट अप पे अपलोड। यह रहा।
इसका लिंक मैं आपको डिस्क्रिप्शन में भी
दूंगा। डायरेक्ट यहां से कॉपी करके इसको
इधर पेस्ट कर देना। खुद से लिखने की जरूरत
नहीं है। ठीक है? और बाकी का कोड मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं।
पूरा का पूरा मैंने आपको कोड दिखा दिया
है। ठीक है? कोई दिक्कत वाली बात नहीं है।
अब आ जाते हैं चैट अंडरspy
वाली फाइल पे। इसका पूरा का पूरा कोड यह
रहा अपडेटेड वाला।
अगेन मैं आपको बता रहा हूं। कोई भी इशू मत
क्रिएट करना। पूरा का पूरा सिंटेक्स सेम
होना चाहिए। कोड सेम होना चाहिए, स्पेलिंग
सेम होनी चाहिए और हर एक चीज सेम होनी
चाहिए। तभी यह कोड वर्क करेगा क्योंकि
आपको पता है भाई कितना मतलब सेंसिटिव होता
है मामला। ठीक है? फिर ग्रॉस सर्विस आ
जाते हैं यहां पे और यह रहा इसका कोड।
और गाइस यार मैं बहुत मेहनत करता हूं
वीडियो बनाने में। अभी भी आप देख सकते हो
लिटरली यार इट्स लाइक सुबह के 4:00 बज गए
हैं वीडियो बनाते बनाते। 12:00 बजे बैठा
था। तो यार सब्सक्राइब कर दो। बेल आइकॉन
को ऑल पे सेट कर दो। सपोर्ट दिखाया करो
गाइस। inा पे भी फॉलो करो यार। हर जगह
मतलब समझ रहे हो ना आप? ठीक है? तो 1
लाख्राइबर भी कंप्लीट करने हैं। तो ग्रॉक
अंडरस्कोर सर्विस वाली फाइल का यह कोड है।
रियल टाइम वाली फाइल का कोड दिखा देता हूं
मैं आपको।
सो गाइज़, यह कोड था हमारी रियल टाइम
अंडरस्कोर सर्विस.py वाली फाइल का। ठीक
है? तो आराम से लिख लो और वीडियो को पॉज
करके मस्त एकदम लिखो। इसको कोई भी इशू मत
क्रिएट करना और सिंटेक्स प्रॉपर होना
चाहिए। स्पेलिंग प्रॉपर होनी चाहिए। हर एक
चीज बिल्कुल सेम लिखना। ठीक है? और यह कोड
है हमारी वेक्टर अंडरs स्टोर डॉटpy वाली
फाइल का। ठीक है? तो इसको भी सेम लिखना।
सो गाइज़, हमने यहां पे पूरा का पूरा कोड
लिख लिया है बैक एंड फ्रंट एंड सब कुछ।
ठीक है? अब रह गया है सिर्फ यूटिल्स वाला।
ठीक है? तो मेरे हिसाब से यूटिल्स वाले का
जो कोड है वह यह है। ठीक है? कुछ चार
फाइल्स हैं यहां पे। एक इनिट फाइल है जो
कि खाली छोड़नी है आपको। एक की रोटेशन
फाइल है उसके अंदर यह कोड आपको लिखना है।
ठीक है? और एक रीिट्राई वाली फाइल है
जिसके अंदर आपको यह कोड लिखना है इतना सा
बस। ठीक है? और एक टाइम इनफो फाइल है
जिसके अंदर आपको यह कोड लिखना है। ठीक है?
मेरा गला बैठ गया भाई बोलते। बट फिर भी अब
हमारा पूरा का पूरा कोड कंप्लीट हो गया
है। अब आपको कुछ नहीं करना। एक वर्चुअल
एनवायरमेंट बना लेना है। ठीक है? और उसके
बाद आपको रन डॉटpy को यहां पे रन करना है।
ठीक है? जैसे ही आप इसको रन करोगे तो आपका
पूरा का पूरा जो एi है वह मस्त एकदम काम
करेगा। अभी यहां पे वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट
एक्टिवेट हो चुका है और जो हमारा जावे है
वो स्टार्ट हो रहा है। ठीक है? तो गाइस अब
इस कोड को रन करते हैं टेस्ट करके और मैं
आपको एनg rock का भी यूज़ करके सब कुछ करके
दिखाऊंगा। ठीक है? तो फटाफट से इसको रन
करते हैं और यहां पे ओपन हो चुका है। और
यहां पे मैं टर्मिनल ओपन करके इसमें एक
कमांड एंटर करूंगा।
एनg http 8000 और जैसे ही मैं एंटर करूंगा
इस पर मैं क्लिक करूंगा और यहां पर हमारा
जावस जो है ओपन हो जाएगा। वन सेकंड प्लीज
आई कैन आंसर एनी क्वेश्चन ओपन क्लोज एप्स
एंड वेबसाइट जनरेट इमेज प्ले म्यूजिक राइट
कंटेंट एंड सर्च फॉर इन आई विल डू माय
बेस्ट टू असिस्ट यू सर
व्हाट इज Python प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज
जस्ट अ मोमेंट प्लीज Python इज अ हाई लेवल
इंटरप्रेटेड प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज नोन
फॉर इट्स
सो गाइस यू कैन सी इट्स वे टू परफेक्ट एंड
एवरीथिंग इज गुड सो आई होप आपको आज की
वीडियो पसंद आई होगी मेक श्योर आप वीडियो
को लाइक कर दो Instagram पे फॉलो कर लो
Telegram चैनल हमारा जॉइ कर लो। ठीक है?
और ग्रुप चैट भी जॉइ कर लो। सब कुछ आपको
वहीं पे मिल जाएगा। और वेबसाइट पे जाके
सब्सक्रिप्शन ले लो भाई। कितने का ही है।
सिर्फ इतने का ही है। ठीक है? अदरवाइज आप
खुद से लिख सकते हो। इट्स कंप्लीटली फ्री।
इट कंप्लीटली डिपेंड्स ऑन यू। ठीक है? एंड
सारी चीजें आपको डिस्क्रिप्शन में मिल
जाएंगी आज की इस वीडियो के। और एनg का यूज
करके अब आप इस वेबसाइट को आप मतलब किधर भी
यूज कर सकते हो। उस लिंक को आप अपने फोन
में खोलोगे तो मस्त एकदम आपके फोन में वह
वर्क करेगा। और आज की इस वीडियो के लिए
इतना ही गाइस। मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट वीडियो
में।